let's start there with rick newheisel
cbs sports college football analyst and
a man who always makes me smarter every
time i talk to him about football
rick how are you this morning ep i'm
well and i want to congratulate you on
that great showing last night the sports
emmy thank you
outstanding thank you for those of us
who were not even nominated
real thrilled that you had that kind of
evening
all right so sec acc big 12 still trying
to play football is admirable or
reckless
you know that's uh to each his own for
me it's admirable
uh because i still haven't seen any
statistic that tells me a college
football player is any safer
uh not playing football i mean
there's the the the thing that uh
strikes me as i look at uh what the pac
12
and big ten did yesterday is that many
of these campuses are inviting students
back
they're going to be in on campus housing
uh
how are you protecting them from covet
19
any more than you could be protecting
your football team
uh given all the protocols and all the
testing numbers that seem so positive
jim harbaugh gave out a list of his
numbers
we had lance leipold on the head coach
at buffalo
of course the mac has decided not to
play he said 662 tests three positives
i mean those numbers seem reasonable
uh but again it's all your your risk
tolerance
and uh so i'm i'm with the kids that
want to play i'm with the coaches that
want to coach
i'm i'm with the schools that uh think
that they can do this
as safely as the mbas going forward as
safely as
national hockey leagues going forward uh
i think it can be done
what do you think the collateral damage
is going to be to the big ten and pac-12
well as a pac-12 apologist i
feel very fortunate that the big ten's
with them i had
fear that it was going to be the pac-12
alone and that would have been
absolutely devastating for their brand
uh
long term the fact that the big ten has
chosen not to do
not to play football in the fall is
helpful to the pac-12 because it gives
them some cover
but i think what both those conferences
have to do is tell us what happened in
the five days
since or six days since the big ten
released a schedule
what new medical information do they
have
because if it is in fact new medical
information the rest of these
conferences deserve to have it as well
and that's what i wanted to know if i
got the doctors from
the acc and scc to get together with the
doctor's medical community with the big
ten and pac-12
i would just love to have that
information disseminated
just 100 like i want i want to know we
we need to know this information because
you got if i'm sending my kids back to
an acc and scc school
or i'm sending them to a pac-12 or big
ten school feels like there's a
different
feel uh in those communities here and
i'd love for those doctors to kind of
cross-pollinate here with information
absolutely it's like watching news today
uh
in in our country depending on what
channel you turn on you're gonna get a
flavor of news
and now we're getting flavors of medical
information and i think uh
that's ridiculous this is too important
uh to not know everything there is to
know but it is
concerning when you have doctors that
are saying this is doable this is uh
achievable and there's no reason not to
proceed and then
you have two conferences yesterday stand
up in front of us and say it's just not
safe
uh it makes us all wonder what happened
especially
when you go through the process of
creating a schedule
with all sorts of flexibility built in
for
what where it's going to be perceived uh
spikes and
covet cases so that you could move games
and such and now all of a sudden you're
deciding
uh elsewhere you wonder if they're the
conspiracy theorist and all of us
wonders if there's something else afoot
i wonder if jim delaney was still the
big ten commissioner if this would have
happened rick
interesting question and what also is
interesting about the big ten
as opposed to the pac-12 is all the
disconnect right
over the weekend all these coaches
coming out and speaking
they want to save their programs ryan
day scott frost
uh james franklin jim harbaugh that you
know those are power programs
and those guys and even today nebraska
looking for another place to play
that is uh as disharmonious as you can
imagine
in the early uh portions of kevin
warren's tenure there
we're talking to rick newheisel cbs
sports college football analyst and
of course former college coach if you
were back at ucla
or colorado or washington like
what would you be doing what would you
be saying
you'd be trying to hang on to players
because
you have to wonder if you're penne
sewell that star
offensive tackle for oregon if he's not
getting a bunch of phone calls right now
i mean there's no way that the ncaa is
going to stop anybody from transferring
if this was going to be in fact their
last year in college
there's no uh place to play here at the
in eugene
i can i go to alabama could justin
fields go back to georgia
i think absolutely and i if i'm nick
saban i'm on the phone to justin fields
uh absolutely i'm on the phone to justin
fields and justin you want to i know
you've got
one more year you're thinking about uh a
glorious nfl career after that we got a
place where you can uh
polish your uh skill set and get ready
for that uh next challenge but
i i if i'm a coach i'm having that
conversation with my players and trying
to keep
as bright side of a scenario as i can
so that i can sustain my program
is it legal for nick saban to reach out
to justin fields at ohio state
well legal is a terminal
you won't do it directly okay there will
be there is a third party right
the coconut telegraph if you will how
would you do it how would you do it
you'd go to the high school coaches it's
always go through the high school
coaches and
and uh you know in in the world it's six
degrees of separation and coaching it's
two
so it doesn't take long yeah i'm just
trying to figure this out and then
spring football which i don't
know how likely that is because i can't
ask these kids
let's say you're a sophomore now and
you're going to play
in the spring and then you're going to
play in the fall
i would just skip the spring and play in
the fall if i thought i was going into
the nfl rick the likelihood of
the big ten or pac-12 playing spring
football is what
i i think less than 50 percent i mean i
think we might have kind of a glorified
spring game
something to you know one-off type of
game where you get a scrimmage you know
where
two big programs play and i think there
are a lot of people that have been
looking forward to that over the years
but
but you just canceled seasons on the on
the basis of health safety and wellness
and i guarantee you we can go back and
look at the data
and and talk about how many games can
you play how many collisions can you
take i mean it wasn't so long ago
concussion
was on every everybody's uh tip of their
tongue in
in the cte and the first
uh the c stands for chronic too many
hits
you're already talking these aren't nfl
players because the nfl is getting ready
to go
right so i i don't know the likelihood
of it
where is the ncaa president mark emmer
in all of this
well i heard you talking about mr emmert
and would i i want you to know he's an
economist
okay which means he has an economy of
words
like this is disheartening thanks
commissioner
this is uh distressing thanks
commissioner
he he's powerless in the world of
college football the power lies in the
hands of these commissioners
uh he doesn't ha now if this were
college basketball we'd be hearing more
from him
because they run the tournament but in
this particular case especially with all
these student activist groups out there
he's going to remain on the sideline in
this deal
good to talk to you hope you're well i
am well and
again congratulations on that emmy man
thank you
no i lost no we lost oh oh i
i'm sorry yeah yeah i got the wrong memo
yeah we kind of performed the way you
did when you were at colorado and ucla
and where you are wow wow go ahead and
go ahead and rub it in thank you coach
all right boys take care that's rick
newman rick newhazzle cbs sports college
football analyst